[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله نج الشيخ علي
الحاتم امير عشائر دليم واحد قه ثوار
العشائر في الانبار نجى من قصف استهدف
منزله الاحد بعد ساعات من قصف مماثل
استهدف منزله ومجلس الشيخ رافع المشحن شيخ
عموم قبيله الجميله في العراق نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر نناقشه في محورين ما الذي دفع
السلطات العراقيه الى استهداف زعماء
العشائر في الانبار في هذه المرحله وما هي
الانعكاسات السياسيه والعسكريه
والاجتماعيه المحتمله لمثل هذا
التوجه في سياق تصعيد حكومي للمواجهات
المستمره منذ فتره مع مقاتلي عشائر
الانبار استهدفت القوات الحكوميه العراقيه
منزلي اثنين من زعماء العشائر في العراق
هما الشيخ علي الحاتم امير عشائر دليم
والشيخ رافع المشحن شيخ عموم قبيله جميله
في العراق حدثان نظر اليهما بالكثير من
القلق لكونهما قد يشكلان من وجهه نظر
البعض منعطفا مهما في سياق مواجهات
الانبار التي طالما اكدت حكومه الملك انها
ليست مواجهه ضد اهل الانبار او زعمائها
وانما هي حرب تخوضها ضد عناصر القاعده
ومقاتل الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق
والشام هذا حرب الانبار ما هي حدودها والى
متى تفيد روايات شهود العيان في الرمادي
بقصف القوات الحكوميه احياء البكر والضباط
والحوز وما قد يعقد تفاصيل الازمه اكثر هو
استهداف منازل شيوخ عشائر مواليه لما يعرف
بمجلس ثوار العشائر في محافظه الانبار
المضطربه فقد نجا امير عشائر دليم علي
الحاتم بعد قصف منزله علي الحاتم احد قاده
ثوار العشائر وسبق ان هدد رئيس الوزراء
نور المالكي بنقل المعركه الى بغداد اذا
لم يسحب جيشه من الانبار ويتوعده الان
بالرد على استهداف منازل شيوخ العشائر هذه
ضربه الضعفاء عند ما يستخدم هذه الطائرات
من بعيد ويقصف النازل هو لو كان لو كان
عنده هدف حقيقي لمقاتله الارهاب ما يضرب
بيوت الناس ووظائف ولكن احنا ناكد ان شاء
الله بالايام المقبله راح يكون موقفنا
حاسم ضد يعني تواجد الجيش المالكي وان شاء
الله الرد الرد هذا ه اليومين ان شاء الله
را يكون الرد واضح وراح تشوفونه انتم ان
شاء الله وفق شهادات اهل المنطقه استهدف
القصف ايضا منزل ومجلس رافع المشحن شيخ
عموم قبيله الجميله في العراق الازمه التي
بدات في الانبار نهايه العام الماضي اخذت
ابعادا طائفيه وقبليه خطيره ففي الوقت
الذي يقول فيه رئيس الوزراء نور المالكي
انه يحارب تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
العراق والشام تتهمه العشائر المعاديه له
بشن حرب بالوكاله عن ايران ضد السنه
استمرار الصراع في الانبار ادى الى مقتل
مئات وفق بعض المصادر ونزوح الاف العائلات
هربا من الاشتباكات وقصف الطيران ذريعه
مكافحه الارهاب اكسبت المالك دعما سياسيا
وعسكريا من واشنطن تدهور الوضع الامني لا
يشغله عن التحضير للانتخابات البرلمانيه
المقرره في ال من ابريل المقبل منطقيا على
الارجح لن تجرى الانتخابات في الانبار
والاخطر هو سياسه استبعاد شخصيات من
الترشح بعضهم بسبب قضايا جنائيه هي في
الحقيقه قضايا سياسيه بامتياز العراق
موعود بايام اخر من الصراع من اجل السلطه
تحت مسميات
مختلفه ومناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
لندن الدكتور غسان العطيه مدير المعهد
العراقي للتنميه
والديمقراطيه ومن بيروت عباس الموسوي مدير
المركز الاعلامي العراقي كما ينضم الينا
عبر هاتف من الانبار الشيخ احمد مشعان
بديوي شيخ عشيره البعلي مرحبا بضيوفنا
الكرام نبدا معك شيخ البدي بحكم انك قريب
مما يجري الان على الارض انتم كيف نظرتم
الى هذا التطور الاخير استهداف
شيخي يعني الشيخين احمد او علي الحاتم
والشيخ مشحن الجميلي امس وما الذي يعنيه
لكم انتم هذا
التطور
السلام عليكم وعلى قناه الجزيره ومشاهدي
قناه الجزيره السلام وركاته
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نصر من الله وفتح
قريب صدق الله العظيم اخي العزيز منذ هجمه
اللي قام
بها حكومه المالكي الممثله بالحكومه
الايرانيه بدات الهجمه على الانبار بعد
اعلانه الصريح امام شاشات التلفزيون وعلى
مس اسمع مرا العالم من قال سوف هذه
المعركه معركه بين انصار الحسين وانصار
يزيد بدا بخطط ممنهجه وفي كل وقت يظهر ب
باحد هذه الخطط
بدا باقتحام الانبار بحجه الارهاب ويعلم
العالم العربي والعالم الاسلامي بان
الانبار مكونه وممثله بعشائر الاصيله
فثارت عشائر الانبار بتصدي هذه الهجمه
الصفويه و عندما تحالف بعض الشيوخ العشائر
الذي تراهم بدراهم بشه فبدا يهجم ويضرب
و طيب يا يا شيخ بديوي يعني هذ هذ هذه
الخلفيه معروفه ونتابعها بشكل يومي في
الاخبار ولكن الان هذا تطور المعطى
الميداني الجديد ان انه يتم استهداف شيوخ
العشائر قلت الشيخ علي الحاتم ثم
الشيخ امير الجميله عموم قبيله الجميله
رافع المشحن ماذا يعني لكم انتم ذلك هذا
التطور هذه هذا التطور يقصد به الشيوخ
العشائر العربيه الاصيله التي تدافع عن ع
عروبتها واصالتها ودينها ومحافظتها وقام
بضرب دواوين الشيوخ العشائر في الانبار
قبلها مضيف الشيخ الجو المطلق والشيخ
فرحان الجاس
والشيخ والشيخ خالد العذوب وبدا امس بضرب
احد قاده ثوار العشائر هو الشيخ رافع
المشح شيخ عشيره جميله والشيخ علي الحاتم
امير الديم الذي ارسل لهم المالكي مبالغ
طائله لحرف مسارهم عن هذه القضيه ورفضوا
والان المالكي بدا بخطته الجديده استهداف
شيوخ العشائر الاصيله الذي هي تمثل
الانبار وتمثل العروبه في الانبار
والمالكه بدا الضغط والهج الشرسه على هذه
الدواوي لانها تمثل الثوره الانبار وتمثل
عشار الانبار وثوار الانبار وقبل امس دعا
المالكي بهجم الشريفه بان ها هو جوجه داعش
والقاعده في الانبار هذه الهجمه لم تثني
شيوخ العشائر ابناء العشائر الاصيله بان
يكونوا اعداد تنفيذ لمخطط الفارسي في
الانبار طيب السيد عباس الموسوي من بيروت
ما الذي اضطر حكومه المالكي ان تقصف او
تستهدف زعماء العشائر رغم علمها بحساسيه
الامر وبان هذ هذه الشخصيات لها مكانتها
ورمزيتها في المجتمع العشائري في منطقه
ملتهبه يعني وحساسه في وفي هذا الظرف
بالذات بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي الك
عزيزي والى الضيوف الكرام والمشاهدين
الاعزاء اتصور هو الموضوع لا يعني علي
حاتم السلمان علي حاتم السلمان من
الشخصيات التي افلت في الواقع العراقي وهو
غير موجود والكل يعلم انه قد هرب الى
اربيل لذلك كان هنالك قرار وهذا القرار في
اغلب دول العالم اي مكان تخرج منه اطلاقات
النار على الجيش العراقي او على اي جيش
اخر يرد بالمثل لذلك الموضوع لا يستهدف
ولكن تعودنا في الواقع العراقي دائما علي
حاتم السلمان يعمل هذه الفرقعات الاعلاميه
من اجل ان يعود الى الواقع اسمحلي ولكن
نريد فقط ان نعيش ذاكرتنا قليلا الشيخ علي
الحاتم ليس وحده من استهدف حتى وان كان
غير موجودا كما تقول في بيته هناك خمسه
شيوخ استهدفوا منذ بدايه هذه العمليه
العسكريه ضد ضد الانبار عزيزي عزيزي اول
شيء الموضوع هو الشيخ لا تع يعني حصانه عن
قتل الابرياء عندما يخرج اي انسان على
الاعلام ويهدد بقتل الجيش العراقي مهما
كان موقع السياسي او العشائري هذه لا تعني
حصانه حصانه الدم غير موجوده ان انا اذا
كنت شيخ عشيره ان اقتل ان القانون ما يطبق
هذا كلام ما مقبول في كل دول العالم لذلك
اي شخص واي مكان يستهدف الجيش العراقي
ويقطع ويعمل عصابات على الطريق الخارجي
ويقتل الزوار ويقتل السائقين هو معرض الى
ضربات الجيش العراقي يعني هي فوضه زي ما
يقال يعني هل ثبت ان هؤلاء فعلا قاموا
بمقامه اليس في العراق مؤسسات وليس هناك
قضاء ليس انه محاكمات يفترض ان يتم الامر
على يدها يعني كل من اختلف مع الاخر يقتله
عزيزي لا لا لا عزيز الموضوع ليس الجيش في
معركه في الانبار ضد داعش وكل من يقف مع
داعش هو هدف طبيعي للجيش العراقي هذا لا
يعني عندما انا اخرج الى الاعلام وخرج علي
حاتم وخرج غيره وهدد الجيش العراق العراقي
وتبنى بعض القتل لابناء الشعب العراقي هذا
يعني عندما تكون اماره علي حاتم محصنه هذا
كلام غير منطقي الكلام المنطقي وكن هناك
تناقض استاذ استاذ يعني استاذ موسوي هناك
تناقض تقول بان الجيش العراقي يخود حرب ضد
ما يسميها القاعده او تنظيم داعش كما تصفه
انت ولكن هل علي الحاتم ما تسميه داعش
الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق والشام هل
الشيوخ الاخر الاربعه الاخرون من هذه
التنظيمات سياسي استذ عبد الصمد استاذ عبد
الصمد داعش التعبير السياسي والتعبير
المجازي لكل من يقاتل الجيش العراقي ويرفض
ويرفض العمليه السياسيه بالتاكيد هو داعش
نفس خطاب داعش لا لا هذا هذا الواقع هذا
الواقع الانسان عندما ياتي ويقاتل الجيش
الوطني لبلد بالتاكيد هو يتفق يتفق مع
داعش وم القاع اسمحلي دكتور غسان العطيه
خط احمر جديد في منظومه البناء الاجتماعي
يقول البعض في العراق تجاوزته الان حكومه
المالكي اذا استهدفت حكومه المالكي هؤلاء
الشيوخ وهم رموز قبائل وعشائر ولهم يعني
صيتهم ولهم تاثيرهم في على هذه القبائل من
مع من سيكون الحوار ومع من سيتم البحث عن
مخرج امن هذه
الازمه
شكرا ما يجري في العراق حقيقه ماساه
ونموذج للفرص المضا الان المعركه هي معركه
الولايه الثالثه وبالتالي من يجعل الولايه
الثالثه هي الاولويه لها مستعد ان يسترخص
اي اجراءات اخرى الولايه الثانيه اللي
جاءت بالسيد المايك الحكم بتوافق امريكي
ايراني كحل وسط هذا التوافق كان اعطي فرصه
ان يكرس الى حكومه مشاركه حقيقيه ومصالحه
وطنيه ونج انفسنا بسنه 2014 بانتخابات
هادئه ومجتمع مستقر وثروه كبيره ينعم بها
جميع العراقيين المؤسف الاربع سنوات
الماضيه بدل ما تكرس هذا الشيء كرست العكس
تماما وتذكرنا بانتخابات 2005 2005 اصروا
على اجرائها برغم مقاطعه قطاع كبير من
الشعب العراقي النتيجه كانت الانتخابات
بدل 2005 بدل ما تؤدي الى انفراج الوضع
عقدت الوضع ودخلنا بحرب اهل
استمرت ثلاث
سنوات النقطه الجوهريه من يريد انتخابات
حره وشريفه ونزيهه وعادله عليه ان يبدا
بالمصالحه الوطنيه اولا قبل الانتخابات
والا تصبح انتخاباتنا ذات بعد واحد كما
حصل في الان في قرم او في القرم او في غير
الان في العراق الكلام
كه ترى كل ما يجري الان له ارتباط وثيق
بهذا الموعد الذي ينتظره العراقييون وه
انتخابات تشريعيه
القادمه ب ب بدون شك بدون شك على ساحه
الانبار ال الرابط وكيف يمكن ان ما الذي
يمكن ان يجنيه المالكي من توتير الوضع
عسكريا حتى يفوز بعهده
ثالثه هذا السؤال جدا مهم الخارطه
السياسيه الوض داخل الانبار وانا كان لي
فرصه ان ازول الانبار اكثر من مره الان
هناك من قطاع مهم من الشعب في الانبار ياس
من العمليه السياسيه ويجد ان بانحرافه
تؤكد وتؤسس الى دكتاتوريه ولا مجال لان
يجد حل بعد ما اعطوا اربع سنوات للحكومه
لايجاد حلول وهناك طرف يتمثل ب حزب متحدون
وشخصيات اخرى اللي هي بالحكومه تقول دعنا
نواصل العمليه بالعمليه السياسيه ونشترك
بالانتخابات وهناك طرف اخر مرتبط برئيس
الوزراء من رئيس
المحافظ وشخصيات اخرى من الصحوات هذه ربطت
مصيرها مع الحكومه هل ثلاث اجزاء الان
السؤال ونجح السيد المالكي في دائما في
تقسيم خصومه وفرق تسد الان في ضرب
اي مجلس الثوار العشائر هو يريد اضعافه
باضعاف عمليا المستفيد الحقيقي هو المحافظ
والمجموعه المرتبطه برئيس الوزراء لان
المتحدون اخرين رئيس قائمه متحدون وهو
السيد رافع عيساوي تم منعه من المشاركه
بالانتخابات رئيس القائمه فالان متحدون
يجد نفسهم في وضع صعب جدا فالشارع
الانباري بدا ينتقدهم ان انتم واقفين على
مجرد بيانات وتصريحات وبالتالي ينقسم
الشارع بين مؤيدي المحافظ ومؤيدين السيد
رئيس الوزراء وما بين المجلس العشائري
مجلس العشائري سيقاطع مقاطعه تامه هذا دك
انتخابات ولو ب 5% يعني كل هذا اذا
افترضنا ان ولو ب 5%
فسفو هذا هذا اذا افترضنا جدلا ان المالكي
سيفوز وسيت تب له مره اخرى ولايه ثالثه
تؤول اليه ولكن ماذا سيجني هو او العراق
اذا كان سيصل الامر الى الى ذلك والعرب
السنه خارج العمليه السياسيه واستهداف
رموز وزعماء الانبار ما زال متواصلا و
يعني وكل ذلك له نع كاسات اكيس سياسيه
واقتصاديه واجتماعيه وهذا س نبحثه بعد
قليل بعد الفاصل مشاهد الكرام نعود اليكم
بعد
قليل اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في
هذه الحلقه التي تناقش ابعاد ودلالات
تركيز القوات العراقيه الحكوميه على
استهداف زعماء العشائر في العراق نرحب من
جديد بضيوفنا الكرام نعود الى الشيخ احمد
مشع بديوي شيخ عشيره ال البعلي معنا عبر
الهاتف من الانبار شيخ احمد مشعان ما هي
توقعاتك لماله الامور في العراق في ضوء
استهداف
شيوخ عشائر وقبائل القبائل في
الانبار اخي العزيز بالنسبه للثوره في
الانبار بعد
هذه المخططات الذي تنكشف لابناء عشائرنا
في الانبار والمحافظات المنتفض يوم بعد
يوم اخو
بان هذه رسائل من المالكي بان هذا
الاستهداف مخطط اله وممنهج اللهه ونقول
لجميع عشائر العراق وجميع عشائر المحافظات
المنتفض
واسال على سؤال ضيفك الموسوي عندما يقول
علي الحاتم وامير تليم والشيخ مشحن والشيخ
فارس المشعال الديوي والشيخ دول غير
محصلين اقول له هل هل رموز السنه اصبحوا
اليوم عند حكومه المالكي هم سلعه رخيصه
يتاجر بها
لدول دول المتحالف معها هل هل يوجد المالك
الان اخي العزيز وليعلم الشعب العربي
جميعا والمحافظات المنتصبه المالكي لن
يحكم الا السنه الان
الان المالكي لن يحكم الا المحافظات
السنيه هناك هناك في في في محافظات
اخواننا من الشيعه هناك كل من يحكم نفسه
بنفسه المالك الان كشر بانياب على اهل
السنه والثوره قائمه
و احمر والعشائر حتى اعود لسؤالي شيخ انا
انا ابحث عن مالات الامور يعني انعكاسات
ما يجري هل بعد استهداف زعماء العشائر هل
سيبقى الوضع كما هو هل بعد تهديد علي حاتم
بانه سيكون هناك رد هل المواجهات ما بعد
استهدافهم ستكون كما كان كما ما بعد ما
قبلها نعم هناك في الثوره ثوره عشائر
الانبار واقولها ثوره عشائر الانبار لم لم
مثل ما يدع المالكي وعصابته بين داعش
والقاعده الانبار لم يجد ويها داعش
والقاعده الانبار ثوار عشائر ولدهم خطط
ولدهم مجلس عسكري والخطط والايام القليله
القادمه سوف ترون وتشاهد العالم كله ماذا
راح يفعل بجيش العصابه المالكي و ومليشيات
المالكي والايام القليله القادمه سوف
تشهدون تصاعد كبير في ثوره عشائر الانبار
شكرا لك الشيخ احمد مشعان بديوي شيخ عشيره
البعلي معنا عبر الهاتف من انبار نعود مره
اخرى الى ضيفنا الكريم من بيروت عباس
المسوي مدير المركز الاعلامي العراقي
استاذ مسوي يعني سمعت ما قاله الشيخ احمد
مشعان وكما قال ايضا علي حاتم هناك تهديد
بتصعيد وبان المرحله ربما قد تكون مرحله
جديده الم تتحسب حكومه الملكي لخطر كهذا
حينما تصب
الوقود يعني الزيت على النار وتزيد من
توتير
الوضع عزيزي الموضوع ليس كما يتصور البعض
هذا الخطاب الخشبي صار سنوات سمعه سنصل
بغداد سنحطم سنضرب الصفويين سنضرب هذا
التحصن بالخطاب الطائفي السنه واستهداف
السنه هذا هذا كلام استهلك الموضوع الان
اذاو عدنا الى الواقع الفعلي للانبار
واجراء الانتخابات هنالك محور موجود في
الانباري مثل رافع العيساوي والعلوان
وغيره من هؤلاء المحور السعودي هذا المحور
السعودي انهزم الان في العراق دمر لذلك
السعوديه تعمل على تدمير العمليه
السياسيه مره اخرى تتناقض مع نفسك مره
تقول دوله العراق الدوله الاسلاميه في
العراق والشام المره مره ثانيه تقول هؤلاء
زعماء القبائل والعشائر الذين يمثلون جهات
ما خارجيه يعني على اي روايه تريد ان
تستقر سيدل ما خل لا لا لالا انا ما اتنا
قض ويا نفسي ولكن انا واضح جدا لان لان
هذه مجموعه جبهه النصره هي بصناعه سعوديه
وهذا موثق هذا هذا كلام غير ليس كلام
الدعاء يعني هاي طريقه الاستعراضات
السعوديه الاخيره باصدار حكم السجن
استعراضات طبعا جبهه النصره هي صناعه وهذا
هذا موثق والايام ست تخرج لكم مئات
الوثائق العراقيه التي تدعم الاف
السعوديين الذين جاؤوا من السعوديه لتدمير
العمليه السياسيه انا اعود الى الانتخابات
واتكلم بالسياسه الان هنالك ش موجود من
رافع العيساوي ومن غيره لا يريدون
الانتخابات في الانبار وهنالك المحافظ
وعشائر كبيره وشيخ عشائر الدليم علي
السلمان قد سحبت منه اماره الدليم قبل
فتره ببيان واضح وكان معروف هذه المجموعه
الان الانبار شبه مستقره المشكله الان فقط
في الفلوجه الموجو المتحصن فيها جبهه
النصره وداعش وبعض البعثيين والضباط
البعثيين لذلك الموضوع ليس موضوع خطر بهذه
الطريقه والتهويل الاعلامي بهذه نعم نعم
يعني هذه قراءه ق قراءه يعني اسمح لي
اقاطعك للوقت دكتور عطيه لك
تعليق نعم يا عزيزي انا انا حقيقه اقوله
بكل الم
ومراره اريد من يطرح يفكر بالعراق كل لا
مجال ما تعلمنا من تج راتنا خلال 10 سنوات
ب
2005 استضعف الاخرين اهملنا اخرين واذا
بهم ينتفضوا بحرب داميه طول ث سنوات الان
اذا هذه الطريقه استمرينا فيها معناتها
هذه الانتخابات فقدت شرعيتها وغير معترف
فيها وبالتالي حتى لو بالنسبه للحاكم او
بالنسبه للحزب الحاكم لو شاركوا
بالانتخابات 5% يقول ها شرعيه وبذلك سيكون
هذا ندخل بهال النتيجه الى مرحله قتال
شديده في العراق انا اتكلم عن نيابه عن
المواطن العادي يريد استقرار الى متى
مصلحه الحاكم تعلو على مصلحه المواطن انا
اقول الان العراق مقبل اذا استمرينا
بهالطريقه الاعتدال القوى العربيه السنيه
المعتدله التي شاركت بانتخابات 2010 واللي
كانت سعيده بالعمل من جملتهم السيد رافع
عيساوي من جملتهم اسامه الجيفي من جملتهم
كثير من الشخصيات السنيه الان تجد هذه
الشخصيات انها تهمش يوم بعد يوم اما
بالاجساد اما بمحاكم او بقرارات بالتالي
هذا الضرر لا يعود على السنه هذا الضرر
يعود على كل العراق يعود على الشيعي على
الكردي على المسيحي فالقضيب لي قضيه
طائفيه السلوك الطائفي ليس من واحد فقط
وانما من الطرفين من هنا اقول من خرجنا من
ه المازق التعيس مع الاسف ليس بايدينا
فالتطرف الشيعي المتمثل برئيس الحكومه
واستخدام هال الشعارات كلها يقابله تطرف
سني كل الطرفين لا يحلوا القضيه العراقيه
العراق اللي كان بحاجه الى شيء من
الاعتدال مع الاسف ضاعت الفرصه ب 2010 كان
ممكن هذا يحصل الان خلاصنا اصبح اما
العراق يدخل بنفق حرب اهليه جديده
والمحافظات اما تتمزق
وانما الموصل تستقل صلاح الدين شكل اخر
وبالتالي نعيش حاله ماساويه و اما يصبح
وفاق اقليمي دولي اي مره ثانيه المفتاح
بيد الايرانيين والامريكان هل ايران
مصلحته يتمزق العراق استاذ موساوي استاذ
موساوي انا عذرا المقاطعه دتور دكتور غسان
لان الوقت ضيق استاذ موساوي يعني الان
ماذا حصد المالكي حصد من هذا الاسلوب
الامني العسكري في
مواجهه اهالي الانبار ومطالبهم ماذا جنى
المالكي حتى لو فاز بولايات ثالثه هل
سيستقيم يستقيم الامر له في عمليه سياسيه
همش منها العرب او خرجوا منها
طواعيه الموضوع ليس موضوع المالكي وماجن
المالكي الموضوع اهالي الانبار كانوا رهاء
بيد هؤلاء المتطرفين القتله ما قام به
المالكي هو استجابه الى الى مطالب مجلس
محافظه الانبار ومحافظ الانبار بتخليصه من
هؤلاء القتله الموضوع ليس موضوع ولايه
ثالثه ولايه ثالثه يحددها الصندوق
الانتخابات اذا حصل المالكي على نعم على
على نتائج جيده بالتاكيد ستكون اسمح لي
استاذ موساوي نعم نعم اسمح لي الوقت ضيق
استاذ غسان عطيه الموضوع ليس موضوع
المالكي في 30
ثانيه يا سيدي كل قضيتنا اليوم هي موضوع
الولايه الثالثه كانت الفرصه امام السيد
المالكي ان يحل قضيتنا لو قبل سنه قبل م
اقتراح انتخابات مبكره يستقيل وتشكل حكومه
انتقاليه من تكنوقراط لا تشارك في
الانتخابات وهذا مع اعمال السيد الغنوشي
في تونس كانت حلت امورنا وان ذاك حتى لو
فاز كان ممكن يكون ولايه ثالثه ليس هناك
مشكله وانما هذ خرابه ثالثه دكتور غسان
عطيه مدير المعهد العراقي للتنميه
والديمقراطيه من لندن شكرا لك نشكر ايضا
من بيروت عباس الموسوي مدير المركز
الاعلامي العراقي اشكركم مشاه الكرام
لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء بحول
الله
[موسيقى]